Anna Kendrick you join us here Britta
Nets at times sad times because the
Great British Bake Off I can't talk
about it no you you're genuine upset
aren't you are you I'm really upset I
mean you're all upset it's fine we've
been doing press together for chosen
she's actually mentioned how like
obsessed hey don't make me some weird no
no it's a very popular show well it
would be excited about cake idiots
yeah I mean I'm very sad but I also is
so great that it sort of immediately
turned melon soo into folk heroes and
we're all so proud of Mary for like
following suit and then it's like course
Paul stayed with your bread ot Eva likes
you don't come to America and be mean to
me I'm so we're so scared would you
actually like if they were like with you
can you bake like would you go on the
celebrity edition okay I can bake but I
like to take my time okay you know I
like to put on a DVD with commentary
bake and that it like fills up my brain
to capacity and I can't be worried about
like nobody likes you
some of us have Adele in the bathtub
anna has DVD commentary and butter and
sugar but actually don't walk her baking
up you like me no no I do I do but we've
got we've got photographic proof of you
liking Baker yes I'm gonna be knee I'll
tell you what that is gram oh yes it was
chilly outside I just come from the
porch of my house
and where's the photo again Derek yeah
that's a real man with a pink mixer okay
[Applause]
he was like sure conversation went but
they sort of walked me over to him and
he said oh hi nice to meet you and I
said nice to meet you